good mornings on this wednesday december
4th today i'm going to try to fit in 51
jokes into one four minute video so
obviously we should probably get started
what did one snowman say to the other
snowman
smells like carrots what do you get when
you throw a hand grenade into a french
bathroom
linoleum blown apart what's red and
smells like blue paint
red paint what is the difference between
a coyote and a flea one house on the
prairie and one prowls on the hairy
what did one wall say to the other wall
let's uh let's meet up in the corner how
come seagulls live by the sea
because if they live by the bay they'd
be bagels why do cows wear bells
because their horns don't work what do
you call a nosy pepper jalapeno business
how come the man driving the train got
struck by lightning well he was a good
conductor how did the snoop dogg wash
his whites
bliatch what happened to the magical
tractor it turned into a
field what a vegetarian zombie say
grains
time flies like an arrow and fruit flies
like a banana
what's brown and sounds like a bell dung
how does luke skywalker get through the
forest
he walks why did the algae in the fungus
get married
they took a liking to each other what do
you get when you put a sheep
on a trampoline a woolly jumper how do
you fit five bulbasaurs and two
charizards onto a bus
you pokemon why did a cowboy have a
wiener dog
because somebody told him to get a long
little doggie
how do you get an eight-year-old deal
you get another 80 year woman right next
to her to yell bingo
what does a teenage boy have in common
with the enzyme helicase they both want
to unzip your jeans
what are the eggs into the boiling water
it'll be a minute before i get hard i
just got laid by a chick luke skywalker
and darth vader are locked in mortal
kombat darth vader pulls luke close to
him my microphone darth vader pulls luke
close to him and says
i know what you're getting for christmas
what how that's impossible i
felt your presence why do chicken coops
only ever have two doors
because if they had four doors they
would be a chicken sedan what's the
difference between a bad golfer and a
bad skydiver one goes
whack darn and the other goes darn
whack i tried to build an irony detector
but the darn thing just won't work
oh why what's wrong with it it detects
everything except irony what did the dog
say when he sat on some sandpaper rough
a duck walks into a bar wearing one shoe
the bartender says
he lost a shoe and the duck says no
i found one what is black and white and
black and white and black and white and
black and white
black white black and white a penguin
rolling down a hill
what's black and white and laughing the
penguin that pushed him after giving up
on being a nanny mary poppins actually
moved to beverly hills and became a
fortune teller and she reads your future
not by looking at the lines on your head
but by smelling your breath
they call her the super california
mystic expert halitosis how many dragon
ball z characters does it take to change
a light bulb just one but it's going to
take about six episodes how many kids
with add does it take to change a light
bulb let's go ride bikes what do you get
when you drop a piano down a mine shaft
a flat miner why did the tomato blush
because it's all the salad dressing
what's the difference between deer nuts
and beer nuts beer nuts are a dollar
fifty and deer nuts are under a buck
what's worse than finding a worm in your
apple
genocide what kind of pants do the mario
brothers wear denim denim denim
i was feeling sad my friend came up and
told me 10 jokes to try and make me feel
better
unfortunately no pun intended why can't
helen keller drive
because she's dead did you hear about
the red ship in the blue ship that
collided
all of the sailors were marooned how can
you tell if it takes hate more than one
day to make a video
because the lighting completely changes
in the middle two peanuts were walking
down the street one was assaulted what
are the zeros out of the eight
nice belt a baby seal walks into a club
what do you call a monkey in a minefield
what did the youtubers say when he came
in fifth place in a race first
if i have one little green ball in one
hand and another little green ball on
the other hand
what do i have the undivided attention
of a leprechaun
why is your sex life like a vlogbrothers
video because it never lasts more than
four minutes
51 jokes put your jokes down there i
might do this again
and my favorite drink that gets put in
the next two days we'll get a free
signed copy of my cd